-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
You made it.
This is gonna be fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Love you, Jimmy!
-I love you, too.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
this is very interesting.
According to a new study,
men spread COVID
more frequently
than women or children.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, once again, "manspreading"
is making life difficult
for everyone else.
[ Laughter ]
Men were like, "You got us.
We finally did something wrong."
[ Laughter ]
But here's some good news.
Today, Pfizer announced
that three doses of its vaccine
effectively fights
the omicron variant.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, everybody who panicked
last week was like,
"Honey, where's the receipt
for those 2,000 rolls
of toilet paper?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, it's a big day for Pfizer
and an even bigger day
for the relieved
Denzel Washington GIF.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, everyone who just got
their third dose of Moderna
is like,
"Um, anything you wanna tell us?
Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"We'll wait, we'll wait.
We're good."
[ Laughter ]
I saw that the prime minister
of Finland apologized
for missing a message
saying to quarantine
because she was out clubbing
till 4:00 a.m.
and left her work phone at home.
[ Laughter ]
Americans are shocked.
They were like,
"You can leave
your work phone at home?"
How does that work?
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the only time
Joe Biden's up at 4:00 a.m.
is to use the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
The only time Joe Biden
ever went clubbing
is when he went
seal hunting as a boy.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Get this --
[ Laughter ]
in a new survey 1 in 3 people
said that during the pandemic
they had to work
in either a bathroom
or a closet.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, New Yorkers are like,
"Yeah, I worked in a closet.
It's called my apartment.
Hello?
I can touch my oven
and my toilet at the same time.
I can touch all the walls
in my place."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, this is great news.
A Confederate statue
that stood alongside
a Tennessee highway for 20 years
has finally been removed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Can we take a look
at the statute?
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-Well, people
are obviously happy
that it's gone
for a number of reasons,
so check out
what some of them are saying.
This person said...
The statue itself said...
[ Laughter ]
Then this person said...
Then the statue of soccer star
Cristiano Ronaldo said...
[ Laughter ]
Then this plaque
of Elvis Presley
spoke up and said...
And, finally, this statue
of Lucille Ball said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
So it seems like everyone's
on the same page.
[ Applause ]
Well, this is cool.
Computer scientists have created
the world's smallest camera,
and it is the size
of a grain of salt.
Look at this.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Even crazier,
it takes a photo
and then spits out
a very tiny Polaroid.
[ Laughter ]
Scientists were like,
"As you can see --
Oh, no. Crap.
Nobody move. Nobody --
Nobody breathe."
[ Laughter ]
"There's $200,000 on the floor."
I read that the
U.S. Captioning Company
just released a list of its most
mispronounced words of 2021,
and topping the list
is "cheugy."
[ Light laughter ]
Cheugy, yeah.
And if you don't believe me,
just turn on your local news.
Watch this.
-Chew..."chew-gee"?
-What the heck is "chew-gee"?
-"Chew-gee"?
-"Chew-gee."
-"Chew-gee".
-Have you ever heard
of "coo-gee"?
-"Chu-gie".
-Called, "cho-gee".
-Shug-- "Shug-ee"?
I don't even know
what that means.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Cho-gie."
[ Applause ]
Guys, I heard that dozens
of camels were just banned
from a beauty contest
in Saudi Arabia
because they received
Botox injections.
[ Laughter ]
Not only that,
one camel was accused
of getting hump implants.
[ Laughter ]
The camel beauty official
who made the decision said,
"You're disqualified,
and what the hell
am I doing with my life?"
[ Laughter ]
They may be out of the
beauty contest for using Botox,
but they just signed on
for the next season of
"Real Camels of Saudi Arabia,"
so I'm excited to see that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's gonna be good.
[ Applause ]
And, finally, a boater found
$1 million worth of cocaine
floating in the water
off the coast of Florida.
Yep. The boater found it
by following a manatee
that wouldn't shut up
about crypto.
[ Laughter ]
Though, if you didn't find
cocaine floating in the water,
did you really
go boating in Florida?
We have a great show.
Guys, we have exactly
eight shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Eight days left ♪
-That is right!
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving one lucky
audience member
a jaw-dropping Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, since -- Oh, yeah.
We don't mess around.
Since there are
eight shows left,
let's open door number eight.
Where is it?
Ooh, even just the door --
even the door looks exciting.
All right, let's see it.
Wow. I need more.
I need more. Let's see.
Let's take it out.
Let's see what it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohh.
Oh.
-Ooh!
-Wow.
That's interesting.
It's like a bonus.
There's, like,
a floating collar.
a bonus collar there.
that's like a floating collar.
Let's see the back.
Let's see.
Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
From "The Tonight Show."
A holiday fruit cake.
All right, let's see who's gonna
go home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at your
seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
Who wants this one?
It's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
419!
Can we unzip it?
Unzip it, unzip it.
♪♪
Hi, bud! Hi!
[ Laughs ]
Come on!
We have the best audience
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I put it on?
-What is your name?
-I'm Paige.
It's so nice to meet you.
-Hey, where you from?
-I'm from Chicago.
-Hey, welcome.
I'm so happy that you're here.
-Thank you so much!
-Thank you for being here.
Now, it's very cold in Chicago.
Even when it's warm,
it's cold in Chicago.
Do you have anything like this?
-I have nothing like this.
The lapels are gorgeous.
-Thank you so much.
I stitched it myself.
Would you like to try it on?
-I would love to try it on.
-Okay, here we go.
[ Audience cheering ]
Oh, this is good.
You can tell already.
Gorgeous.
Do you want to zip it?
Try zipping it.
Yeah, you got to zip it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yes!
Look at this.
Look at that.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Supermodel!
Thank you so much.
Congratulations again.
Guys, stick around.
We're playing "Can You Feel It"
with Nicole Kidman
after the break.
Come on back.
♪♪